view j/s it's a JavaScript framework for
building front-end UIs in view you can
start simple and then progressively add
in the tools and features that you need
to build a complex web application at
its core it provides a way to build
components that encapsulate data or
state in your JavaScript and then
connect that state reactively to a
template in HTML we call these
components declarative views because the
same data inputs will always produce the
same output in the visual UI when we
declare data on this data object it
links or binds it to the HTML on the
template above when the value of the
data changes the component will
automatically rerender or in other words
it's reactive and the framework does a
ton of work under the hood to make sure
that this process is performance across
a huge component tree we can work with
this data in the template thanks to
views HTML based template syntax we can
interpolate a value for expression using
double braces and we also have a variety
of directives to control the behavior of
the HTML based on the data we can use VF
to only render an element when the value
on the right side is truthy and then we
might have a fallback element after that
that's only rendered when the values
fall C with V else we can make the app
interactive by listening to events using
the V on directive we can listen to an
event on an element then run some code
to handle that event on the right side
we can do that directly in the template
or define a custom method and the
components methods object the method has
access to our reactive data and that
means all we have to do is change the
value of the data and the component will
automatically rerender and that's all it
takes to build an interactive reactive
declarative UI component with view the
framework is loved by developers for the
simplicity but also its ability to scale
up in complexity incrementally its
plugin system allows you to easily drop
in things like a router state management
firebase support and more and perhaps
best of all it's not sponsored by some
mega corporation it's not pressured to
push out new releases all the time and
does a great job listening to its
community this has been GU Jas and 100
seconds stay tuned for a full length
tutorial here on YouTube in the near
future and check out my view firebase
course on fire ship if you're ready to
start building a full stack app thanks
for watching and I will see you in the
next one